if you want to get better at sales and  you're the sole owner of your business  what I recommend doing is recording all  of the calls you have the first and  cheapest thing you can do listen to the  ones that went well and listen to the  ones that didn't and then try and see  the differences between the two I think  the better thing to do is to give those  recordings of your sales calls to  somebody who is a really good closer and  then ask them to give you feedback on  the calls and be specific about how you  want them to give feedback just say hey  if I could improve one or two things on  the call what would you tell me to do go  do those things and come back and send  them the next recording so what you're  doing is you're basically recreating a  sales manager salesman relationship with  somebody outside of your organization  and if you want trade with that person  is something that you're better than  them at